which Transformer was only added as a
marketing gimmick for Chevy what was the
hardest scene Michael Bay shot for the
entire series roll into these awesome
details from the billion dollar
franchise the Transformers movies went
on to become massive hits at the box
office but they weren't originally an
area of intense Focus for producer Don
Murphy back in 2007 Murphy explained to
Latino Review that his original goal
when it came to Turning toys into
massive live-action movies was a GI Joe
franchise Murphy had undergone lengthy
conversations with Hasbro about
acquiring the film rights to the
property and Sony Pictures was even
floating the idea of Distributing this
potential film adaptation however real
world events soon cut Murphy's Ambitions
for GI Joe shorts the invasion of Iraq
suddenly made the prospect of adapting
that specific toy into a globally
appealing franchise much less feasible
the then head of Hasbro films Carol
Monroe proceeded to point Murphy in the
direction of the Transformers property
and another Hasbro IP he could adapt
into a film while Murphy didn't have any
childhood Nostalgia for Transformers he
did know that other close creative
Partners like producer Tom DeSanto
harbored a passion for the franchise
recognizing the fan base for those
robots in Disguise Murphy got to work on
getting Transformers off the ground the
result was a pop culture phenomenon that
would have never happened if Murphy's
initial GI Joe plans had gotten off the
ground now I know and knowing is half
the battle Michael Bay stabs at
Transformers movies very wildly in the
characters they Chronicle and even the
time periods they travel to but they all
tend to share one quality a focus on
human characters We Begin these tales as
human beings like Sam Witwicky and Kade
Yeager and a few gigantic sci-fi
Adventures largely through their eyes
with each new Transformers movie the
robotic characters get to be more and
more prominent but the humans are still
at the Forefront of the narrative
believe it or not there was a point in
time when the original live-action
Transformers movie would have been even
more reliant on its human characters
screenwriter Roberto Aussie explained to
IGN that the very first draft of
Transformers was Focus almost solely on
the lead human characters played by Shia
LaBeouf and Megan Fox this version of
the story leans more heavily on a
realistic ramifications of a kid buying
a car that turns out to be a robotic
alien in Disguise that car is sensitive
I mean four thousand dollars just drove
off
Aussie and Company quickly realized that
the inaugural draft just wasn't clicking
and subsequent rewrites took the
skeleton of some whitwicky's storyline
from the first pass and injected more
materials separate from this character
it's understandable of course
Transformers fans would want more robots
in Transformers movies while iconic
Transformers robots like Optimus Prime
and Bumblebee made it to the world of
live-action storytelling with
Transformers in 2007 at the fixtures of
the franchise were not so lucky one
example was RC one of the most famous
lady robots in the entire Transformers
Canon RC would have seemed like a slam
dunk for inclusion into a big
transformers Blockbuster and you better
stay close to me
oh you'd better stay close to me
however she was nowhere to be found in
the franchise's first installment
screenwriter Roberto Aussie revealed via
IGN that RC was originally planned to be
a part of Transformers but female
Transformers were a concept that
required too much time to sufficiently
explain in that original movie wanting
to avoid any potential complications
Aussie decided to leave RC on The
Cutting Room floor and save her for
another day RC would eventually get to
join the live-action incarnation of
Transformers through subsequent movies
like Transformers Revenge of the Fallen
and Transformers rise of the beasts
today some directors tasked with helming
a Blockbuster movie adaptation of a
beloved nerd property of bound to spend
a lot of time talking to the Press about
how much they love it Michael Bay though
has never been one to play by
conventional filmmaking rules the movie
cannot have tracks see the tracks see
the tracks it's no surprise then that
bay has always been open about how he
was downright contemptuous of the
Transformers characters before he signed
on to direct Transformers and in the
mid-2000s as collider reported they
recalled that he missed the boat on
falling in love with Transformers back
in the 1980s because he was too young
when he was first offered the chance to
direct Transformers and attend a seminar
at Hasbro outlining the franchise's
lengthy history they remained skeptical
of the property as he recalled I really
thought what the am I going to
Hasbro for Transformer school I thought
I was going to learn how to fold up
robots however once he Dove deeper into
Transformers Law Bay was entrance with
the universe from there they became a
massive Transformers devotee though he
still sought to make the movie appealing
to the kind of Transformers none fans
that he used to be Transformers
obviously wasn't Michael Bay's first
stab at big budget filmmaking thanks to
Productions like Armageddon and Pearl
Harbor they had already become
synonymous with expensive spectacle
movies however Transformers was no mere
retread of what he'd done in the past
most notably Bayes Blockbuster
filmmaking efforts before Transformers
all centered on Flesh and Blood people
that changed with Transformers which
hinged its plots on towering robots that
were brought into the live-action World
by CGI Wizardry Bay words with animators
closely and constantly imposed
production to make sure characters were
as vividly alive as possible having to
navigate the finer nuances of animated
filmmaking was enchanted territory for
Bay at this juncture in his career but
it was that unfamiliarity that excited
him when he set out to helm Transformers
forget the Decepticons one of the
biggest foes of Transformers had to
overcome was the writer's Guild of
America strike from the end of 2007 to
the very start of 2008 this event
disrupted the entire film and television
industry in North America few projects
were safe not even Mega budgeted tent
poles like Transformers Revenge of the
Fallen could be counted on to escape the
writer's strike and skate in hindsight
director Michael Bay has been quote
vocal about how many Revenge of the
Fallen shortcomings emerged because of
the attempts to make this Blockbuster in
the middle of the writer's strike Bay
explained to Empire that the pressure of
an impending writer strike ensured that
the screenplay for revenge of the all of
them was put together to hastily with
the primary narrative assembled in just
three weeks not only did this provide a
time crunch for creating a story in the
first place but the lengthy nature of
the strike ensure that Revenge of the
Fallen missed out on several months
where its screenplay could have been
polished
I am directly below
enemies
they didn't lay every floor in Revenge
of the Fallen at the feet of the right
to strike he also blames the film's
incorporation of more Fantastical
elements as a key reason it came up
short however it's clear the writer's
strike did this movie no favors it's
often hard to tell the various robots
apart from one another in the Michael
Bay Transformers movies thanks to the
character designs as well as a rapid
fire editing style of the features but
even die hard fans of this franchise
would be hard-pressed to name or
remember jolt a blue Autobot who
transforms into a Chevy Vault jolt's
screen time in Transformers Revenge of
the Fallen is minimal he has no dialogue
and his only personality traitors having
electricity
[Music]
Electrify
turns out the character's lack of
noticeable traits was a byproduct of how
late gelt was added into the script
screenwriter Roberto also explained to
The Hollywood Reporter that Chevy
insisted that there'd be a robot in
Revenge of the Fallen that could help
promote the Chevy Vault considering
these circumstances it's no wonder jolt
was so forgettable
as former's age of Extinction didn't
address or correct any long-standing
problems fans and general audiences
alike had expressed with a Transformers
franchise but that didn't seem to hurt
the movie's bugs off his prospects in
fact age of Extinction became the
biggest feature of 2014 at the worldwide
box office and the only title from that
year to crack one billion dollars
globally further sequels were inevitable
but given how lucrative this franchise
was Paramount Pictures wasn't just
settling for doing a straightforward
sequel this studio was now harboring
Ambitions of Transformers becoming the
next Marvel Cinematic Universe an
expansive Saga spawning countless
spin-offs in March 2015 news broke that
Akiva goldsman and Michael Bay among
others were spearheading a writer's room
that would figure out multiple different
projects set within the Transformers
Universe the Ambitions were high and the
dense Laura Tesla Transformers franchise
beyond the live-action movies gave these
potential new features plenty of
material to utilize however the
potential of this writer's room has yet
to fully come to fruition while the
spin-off movie bumblebee did Premiere in
2018 and took another five years to
write on the Beast to jump into The Fray
the underwhelming box office performance
of Transformers the last night in 2017
probably forced Paramount to pump the
brakes on those big plans for an endless
Transformers Cinematic Universe at least
for a while what was that
was a mistake Michael Bay is no stranger
to battle sequences especially after
doing a decade of Transformers movies
but the filmmaker explained to Fandango
that the fifth entry in this Saga
Transformers The Last Knight contains
the most arduous action sequence in his
career Bay openly admitted that he'd
never done a period era medieval battle
involving Knights before he shot the
opening fight sequence of Transformers
the last night most of Bay's big action
sequences involved Car Chasers and
elements discernably attached to the
modern world suddenly being thrust into
the landscape and battled tactics of a
period era setting was an incredibly
daunting task for Bay Bay also had
personal problems informing why the
sequence was so challenging as his dog
Bone Crusher who had appeared in several
previous Transformers films died the
night before he shot the sequence the
loss of a pet impacted Bay profoundly
and it made the concept of going to
shoot a big action sequence the very
next day a surreal experience however
with so many practical tools including
countless horses and Extras ready to go
for of the shoot Bay had to buckle down
and direct a battle sequence like no
other in his filmography the result was
a set piece that took three days to
shoot but did leave Bay feeling
incredibly accomplished once it was
finished Michael Bay spent an entire
decade of his life making Transformers
movies A decade is a long chunk of time
and while Bae didn't exclusively direct
Transformers movies over those 10 years
he still dedicated most of his life in
that time span to battling robots
naturally with the benefit of
hindsight's Bay has a lot of complicated
thoughts about immersing himself in one
fictional world for so long bay
reflected to unilad that he did have
some regrets about being so ingrained in
the Transformers world for so long he
said I made too many of them Steven
Spielberg said just stop at three and I
said I'd stop the studio begged me to do
a fourth and then that made a billion
two and then I said I'm gonna stop here
and they begged me again I should have
stopped five's good five's good it is
sad you're right it is sad okay but
five's good before he directed bumblebee
Travis night was a director and artist
strictly associated with stop-motion
animated features specifically he was
the man running Leica the outfit behind
groundbreaking films like Coraline and
Kubo in the two strings a latter of
which Knight also directed his career up
to this point was built on totally
original animated properties which made
the idea of him helming a live-action
spin-off of the Transformers movies a
puzzling proposition however Knight
explains a polygon that had been a
massive Transformers fan ever since he
was a kid this especially informed the
prologue set on Cybertron which was
jam-packed with shout outs to Vintage
Transformers media such as a more
classical depiction of Soundwave on
paper night may have seemed like a
strange choice to helmet Transformer
spin-off but his adoration for those
robots in Disguise ensure that he was
just right to give Bumblebee a spin as
its director
foreign